Chancellor Angela Merkel and President
Barack Obama regard each other as allies
even as friends the two countries share
close economic political and cultural
ties but there are differences when it
comes to some key issues the two
countries diverge many Germans lost a
great deal of trust in the u.s. since
news of the NSA scandal broke for years
US intelligence spied on German citizens
and companies the surveillance extended
to members of the government and even
the Chancellor's cellphone
many Germans regard Edward Snowden as a
hero but for a fair number of Americans
he's a traitor Germans are very
concerned about data privacy and
security organizations such as camp Act
campaign against mass surveillance here
in Germany there's a tradition of
criticism of political and economic
power which also derives from our
experiences under two dictatorships the
progressive element of German society at
least identifies with a general culture
of resistance and this element says
citizens must remain vigilant Americans
by contrast tend to worry less about
data privacy many American expats regard
the German passion for privacy with some
dim use meant it is a little bit over
the top for me to say okay we're so
concerned about privacy and I don't want
my name or the face of my child or
anything shown anywhere in a digital
sort of way that for me is too much and
I think we could all maybe stand to be a
little bit more in the middle on that
topic another sticking point is TTIP the
planned transatlantic free trade
agreement the agreement would give
corporations more rights and many
Germans worried that would come at the
expense of consumer interests US
companies would have an easier time
obtaining product approval in the EU
American companies don't understand the
protests
konista home the aim isn't to lower
standards it's to set common standards
which will allow us to offer consumers
and users better products more products
and more interesting products but
standards in the US are often lower than
in Germany food safety is one example we
want to issue our own food regulations
and decide whether we want to allow
genetically modified foods or not we
want to make those decisions on our own
and dirty of corporate lobbyists as few
rights as possible in today's globalized
economy US products and brands are
everywhere in Germany but that doesn't
mean Germany is ready to give up its own
identity